[Música]
Boa noite, meus amigos, minhas amigas.
Bem-vindos a mais uma live. É um prazer
estar com vocês aqui. Deixa eu só mudar
aqui que eu tô aprendendo a usar um
sistema novo aqui.
Ã, deixa eu entender o que está
acontecendo.
[Música]
Não, não é isso. Pera aí.
Bem, vamos começar por aqui. Como vocês
estão? É um prazer tá falando com vocês.
Eu tô fazendo uma transmissão agora
nova, um recurso novo aqui do
Streamyard,
que é uma transmissão diferente para
celular e para
computador e TV, tá? Então, eu mandei os
links diferentes, como vocês viram, eu
gostaria que vocês me dessem o feedback.
Boa noite, Antônio Renato Eliseu.
Boa noite, Cleidivan,
Maria Helena, Alessandra, Regiane, vocês
podem, por favor, me dar o feedback do
áudio, o áudio está bom. E também, por
favor, me falem sobre vocês estão
acompanhando da TV, do celular ou do
computador? Me responda isso, por favor.
Som duplo.
Alguém mais tá tendo som duplo
ou é só Maria Helena?
Está ótimo o áudio, tudo OK no celular?
Então Alessandra tá acompanhando o
celular. Regiane, você tá acompanhando
do celular ou do computador ou da TV?
Nara também me responde, por favor.
Boa noite de Queramobim. Prazer tê-la
aqui conosco, viu, Nara?
Ótimo. Áudio bom, celular, acompanhando
pelo celular. Estou
no note.
Então, Maria, só você que tá tendo aí o
áudio duplo.
Será que é porque você tá?
É, não sei porque que você tá com áudio
duplo, não. É só a Maria Helena que tá
com áudio duplo ou mais alguém tá com
áudio duplo?
Legal. Obrigado, Marlon, pela
informação.
Eh, então, quem tá acompanhando pelo
celular, tá usando o link do celular.
Vocês entenderam que eram dois links
diferentes?
Tem o link do computador e TV e o link
do celular. Vocês entenderam isso?
Tô esperando vocês responderem, tá? pra
gente poder continuar aqui.
Isso. Alessandra tá dizendo que tá
usando o link do celular.
Uma pergunta que eu quero fazer para
vocês. Vocês acham interessante ter
música de fundo ou acha que é frescura?
Acha que ajuda? Não ajuda? Dá para
colocar agora a música de fundo.
Ótimo. Naomi tá dizendo que tá usando o
celular.
Perfeito.
A Alice Vogel disse que não percebeu.
Tudo bem, tranquilo,
tranquilo.
Muito bem.
Sem música fica mais tranquilo, tá?
Vamos ficar sem música mesmo, né? Se
alguém quiser que eu coloque música de
fundo, pode se manifestar. Bem, vamos
começar
a apresentar então aqui.
Ótimo. Clean tá usando o link do celular
também. Alice VG também não quer música.
Marlon também não quer música. Beleza,
sem música. Estamos decididos aí. Bem,
pessoal, me dá só um instantinho
pra gente começar a responder as
perguntas, tá?
Me de só um minutinho.
Pronto.
OK.
Mais um instante.
Bem,
primeira pergunta. Gostaria de saber
informações sobre DMSO e MSM. Nós temos
vídeo, tá, no canal sobre os dois
assuntos, certo?
Alice Vog perdeu o som. Alguém mais
perdeu o som? Vocês estão me ouvindo
ainda
ou ou houve algum problema aí?
Vamos lá. Temos vídeo no canal sobre o
DMSO e o MSM, tá? Vou falar aqui
rapidamente sobre esse assunto,
mas se quiser saber mais detalhes, vai
lá no canal, busca por esses dois temas
que você vai achar os vídeos que eu
tenho lá na parte aberta mesmo, tá?
Então, o DMSO é o dimetil sufóxido e o
MSM é o metil sulfonil metano. São dois
compostos sulfurados, eles são bem
parecidos, mas eles não são exatamente
igual, tá? O DMSO, ele é um sorvete
orgânico, ele se destaca por ter uma
capacidade muito grande de penetração na
pele, então ele é muito bom para ser
associado com outros produtos que você
quer que entre pela pele. Então ele
atravessa as membranas biológicas de
maneira profunda, ele funciona como
transportador
de outras substâncias e possui
excelentes propriedades
anti-inflamatórias por si só. Então ele
sozinho já é antifamatório, já é
analgésico, já é antioxidante e não pode
ajudar outras substâncias entrarem.
Então o demencioló ele é usado
principalmente pela pele, para alívio de
dor, para inflamação, para artrite, para
lesões esportivas, para burs e auxilia
na cicatrização de feridas e também pode
ser utilizado em condições neurológicas.
Tem gente que usa sim o DMSO oral, não é
um uso oficial, então quem está usando
por via oral está usando por própria
conta e risco, porque oficialmente não é
um uso recomendado, apesar que muita
gente usa e não tem problema, tá? O MSM
seria o composto furado para uso oral.
Ele é vendido como suplemento dietético,
ele é muito bom também para detox. Ele
também tem atividade antiinflamatória,
também serve para artrite, para dores
musculares, enxaqueca. Então, MSM eu uso
bastante aqui na minha clínica como um
dos analgésicos naturais que nós temos
disponíveis, tá? Então, geralmente, se
você quer um efeito na pele, você vai
usar um DMSO. Se você quer um efeito
sistêmico, ou seja, no corpo inteiro,
você vai usar o MSM. OK?
Essa é resposta rápida. Tem vídeos no
canal falando sobre um e sobre outro.
Romana está ao vivo, né? Romana, você tá
acompanhando ao vivo? Não sei se está,
mas se tiver, espero que tenha sido
suficiente essa resposta. Tem que ser
mais objetivo agora, porque tem mais
gente no grupo e muita pergunta.
Qual o melhor tratamento para esteatose
hepática além da dieta cetogênica?
Exercício, suplementos e outros.
Bem, a dieta é extremamente curativa,
excelente, ser feita da maneira correta.
Exercício, vocês estão cansados de saber
também que é excelente paraa saúde. E
além disso daí nós temos o quê? Os
tocotrienois e os tocoferidis que são os
oitos vitâmeros da família da vitamina
E. Então, se você for usar sua vitamina
E convencional, né, clássica, que é o DL
alfa tocoferol, eu não recomendo
utilizar ele isolado, mas pode ser
utilizado isolado, você tá pode utilizar
400, 800 unidades do D alfa tocoferol,
OK? Mas eu acho melhor usar os
tocotrienois do urucum, eles são mais
potentes como antiinflamatórios.
Você pode utilizar também pro fígado
ômega-3,
OK? ele vai ajudar eh a baixar a gordura
do fígado. Uma ômega-3 de qualidade para
esse caso, o ideal que seja ômega-3 que
predomina o EPA, né, o Icosa pentenico,
não o DHA, que é mais pro cérebro, a
colina também em fosfatícolina,
outras formas de colina são muito boas
para o fígado. A betaína que a
trimetiloglicina também é muito bom para
fígado. O nac também, nctilcisteína é
muito bom pro fígado. Vitamina C sempre
bom também tá associando
e é muito importante também a criarina.
É, tem o dente de leão, tem alcachofra,
tem um monte de coisa que ajudam no
fígado, tá? O ácido alfalipoico também
ajuda bastante, tá? Esses são os
principais, certo?
em termos de medicações,
eh, que são os fármacos, né, os da
lopatia, para quem é diabético,
pré-diabético, pode pensar em usar
piogglitazona,
porque pode proteger o fígado gorduroso.
Você pode também pensar em usar a
semaglutida, né, que é o Ozempique. Os
análogos GLP1, que é o Zenpique e a e o
Monjaro, né, que é tirepatida,
mas eu preferiria com certeza os
naturais.
Existe também um remédio vendido na
farmácia chamado resmetiron,
que é um agonista beta 3 adenégico que
pode ser utilizado em casos mais graves
de teatose, grau três, tá? Então
primeiro comece com os naturais e se
você tiver um grau três de esteató, você
pode pensar em usar aí os agonistas de
LP1, como o Monjar ou o a semaglutida,
né, o o ZPIC ou a peoglitas ou
resmetiron. OK, vamos paraa próxima.
Na minha cidade tem dois centenários.
Ambos são saudáveis e trabalham na roça.
Essa semana perguntei aos dois qual o
segredo para vert com vitalidade. Ambos
responderam comer bem e não parar de
trabalhar. Eu achei muito boa essa
resposta, viu? Eu não acredito em
aposentadoria no sentido de parar de
trabalhar. Óbvio, você tem direito a
pegar o benefício, pega, mas parar de
trabalhar, eu acho uma fria. Base da
alimentação deles, mocotó de boi com
farofa de feijão, peixe, galinha
caipira, tocinho, batata doce, fruta, só
da época. Eles comem comida natural, né?
Comida da roça não comem
industrializados. OK? Essa é a grande
vantagem deles.
E um pedaço de rapadura no meio da
tarde. Eu não comirei essa rapadura todo
dia, não. Já acho que não é
recomendável.
Falaram ainda que só come o que eles
plantam. Ótimo. Mas esse é o ponto
principal que eu acho disso. Eu acho
ótimo. Acho um exemplo magnífico, né? E
esses dois centenários estão ensinando
para nós o que que significa na prática
comer natural, né? Eh, tem todos os
elementos na alimentação deles que eu
defendo, alimento de verdade que não é
processado, não é industrializado.
Provavelmente eles não estão ingerindo
aí eh metais pesados, né, derivados do
plástico.
O mocotó, vocês sabem muito bem, é igual
o caldo de ossos, né? Ele fornece o
colágeno, gelatina, minerais essenciais.
O tocinho de porco oferece gorduras de
qualidade que não oxidam, né? Diferente
lá do óleo de soja, né? que oxida.
Ah, a galinha caipira tem nutrientes
muito superiores às criadas em
confinamento, né? As galinhas de normais
aí que a gente eh de granja, né? Então
eu acho muito importante não parar de
trabalhar para manter a cabeça ativa,
manter o corpo em movimento. Isso é
muito interessante. Eles devem ter
acesso ao sol e a produção de vitamina D
naturalmente.
Então é bem legal isso daí, tá? Achei
bem interessante eh essa sua
exemplificação.
Bem, vamos paraa próxima pergunta.
Gostaria de saber o que poderia auxiliar
na redução de birirrubinas muito
elevadas paciente, adolescente deve ter
deficiência de G6PD, né? Ah, acredito
que tenha sido com relação aos de um
xarope, não consumo corantes ou outros
que poderia gerar esse aumento.
Bem, vamos lá.
O que que é deficiência G6 PD? Essa é
uma enzima importante para deslocar o
oxigênio da hemoglobina, tá? Quem tem
deficiência de G6PD tem uma tendência,
uma tendência não tem uma doença chamada
favismo, que tem um um problema aí com o
estresse oxidativo. Então, as pessoas
que têm deficiência G6PD não podem fazer
ozônio, por exemplo, não podem fazer
terapias oxidativas como vitamina C em
altas doses ou com peróxido de
hidrogênio ou com azul de metileno, tá?
Então, em pacientes que tem essa
deficiência, a hiperbilirrubinemia,
ou seja, excesso de bilirubina, eh está
associado a exposição algumas
substâncias que desencadeu a hemólise,
ou seja, a quebra da célula vermelha no
sangue da hemácia, né? Então, tem alguns
xaropes que t aditivos problemáticos
que eles não são necessariamente óbvios.
Eh, são corantes artificiais que podem
ter sulfitos, benzoatos, pode ter
salicilatos. Isso pode oxidar as
emácias. Assim como acontece quando você
usa o ozônio, por isso que eles não
podem utilizar o ozônio. O primeiro
passo é identificar, eliminar esse
xarope, permitiu que o corpo dele
neutraliz
neutralize naturalmente o estresse
oxidativo.
E é seria bom fazer um suporte aí da
medicina ortomolecular, né, com as
vitaminas antioxidantes, dá alimentos
verdadeiros para ele, frutas vermelhas
zicas e antioxidantes, vegetais de folha
escura, alimentos ricos e vitamina C,
eh, selena importante, né, da castanha
do Pará, vitaminas do complexo B,
especialmente das carnes dos ovos, B6 e
fole,
excelente hidratação,
eh, muita água para ele poder se
recuperar. disso daí considere dar um
suporte ao fígado com, como eu falei
antes, com cinmarina ou com tocotrienois
ou com alfalipoico
e fazer uma avaliação com o médico que
entenda essa deficiência de 6PD, tá?
Isso é bem importante. Daí para ver se
essa birirubina vai manter alta, se vai
cair. Eu creio que ele vai se recuperar
bem, mas é importante estar sobre essa
orientação e acompanhamento médico. OK.
Ah, vamos pra próxima pergunta. Ah,
ã, fiz exames, entre eles antid
antigliadina e GA e GG e
antitransglutaminase.
Todos não reagentes, valores entre 07 e
3,7.
No caso, eu havia perguntado ao
laboratório se havia necessidade de
consumir algo com glúten e me falaram
que não. Pesquisando, vi que deve-se
consumir glúten para realizar o exame,
sendo que estou desde 2019 sem o consumo
deu reagendar e refazer os exames. Veja
bem, eu não gosto muito desses exames
aí, tá? Eh, eu acho eles pouco úteis na
prática clínica, porque é muito comum
eles verem negativo e você vê que a
pessoa tem intolerância ao glúten, tá?
Se você insiste em fazer esse exame, aí
sim você teria que tá
realmente consumindo glúten para você,
tá? Eu não acho que é uma boa não. E
realmente se você quiser fazer o
antigliadino, anti transglutaminase, é
necessário estar consumindo o glút eh
por seis a 8 semanas antes da da coleta,
tá? Mas eu se fosse você deixasse para
lá e só tirava o glúte da sua
alimentação, OK?
Porque é muito provável ter quando você
reintroduzir, você vai ficar com
inchaço, vai ficar com fadiga,
provavelmente vai ter problemas gastos
intestinais. Eu ficaria afastado da
proteína e deixava esse exame para lá. E
você quiser fazer um outro exame, você
pode fazer o exame do HLA DQ2, HLA DQ8,
tá? Que é um exame também que ajuda
nessa parte aí de ver intolerância ao
glúten. HLA DQ2, HLA DQ8. Deixa eu
colocar na tela aqui para vocês. Pera
aí.
Ah, pá, pá, deixa eu colocar aqui.
Pronto, seria esse daí. Tá bom. Vamos
pro próximo aqui.
Dr. Alan, pessoa em tratamento. Pera aí
só um minutinho, deixa eu só.
Dout. Alan, pessoa em tratamento
quimioterrápico penúltima sessão de
câncer colorretal e que apresenta
elevação das enzimas hepáticas devido ao
tratamento. Poderia se beneficiar de
algum suplemento ou fitoterápico para
baixar essas enzimas sem comprometer o
tratamento? Eu já falei agora na outra
pergunta isso, tá? Mas vamos lá. Eh,
falei aqui alfalipuico, falei de
crimarina, falei de tocotrenóis do
urucum, certo?
E a elevação de enzimas hepáticas
durante a químia é muito esperado, né?
Eh, eles são altamente patotóxicos os
quimioterápicos.
Então,
na verdade, a gente tem que tomar um
certo cuidado também, porque se a gente
dá muito antioxidante durante a
quimioterapia, a gente pode estar
atrapalhando o efeito do quimioterápico,
tá? Mas aí você poderia estar
conversando com oncologista e tá
utilizando esses agentes que nós
comentamos. Vamos repetir aqui. Colina,
nac e trimetioglicina,
eh tocotrenois, dorucum, alfalipoico,
siarina, tá? Se você não pegou, não tem
problema. O vídeo fica gravado, você
pode voltar quantas vezes quiser ir
anotando o que eu falei, tá?
Vamos pra próxima pergunta aqui.
Qual marca de vitamina D3 é confiável?
Olha, eu não tenho tido problema com
vitamina D3, tá? Eh, se você quer
comprar manipulado, eu sugiro na
integritar. Se você quiser comprar eh de
sites que vendem vitamina D, por
exemplo, uma marca que me vem à cabeça
aqui, que é recomendável, que é
confiável, é a Vitafor, né?
Vitaforcional
boa. Ou você pode comprar também a a
Depura lá na farmácia comum, né? na na
drogaria tem a D pura e tem outras
marcas de vitamina D na da drogaria. Eu
não vejo problemas em geral com isso
não, tá?
Mas o o diferencial da vitamina D da
Vita que tem triglicerid de cadeia
média.
Eh, você pode também tá vendo a Sandown,
é uma marca também interessante, a
Nalfus americana, né, mas também é boa.
E lembrar de associar K2, MK7 e o
magnésio para você não ter calcificação
de tecidos moles. Tá bom? Vamos pra
próxima.
Eh, fiquei bem interessado em
suplementar com lío orotato.
Infelizmente não encontrei integritado.
Não, eles não tm na manipulação. Você
tem que importar. Mercado Livre, pessoal
importa. Mas tem que tomar muito cuidado
que tem muito fornecedor ruim lá, né?
Eh, teria alguma outra opção confiável?
Tem o IERB, tá? Tem o IERB. Deixa eu
escrever aqui para vocês. Ierb.
Ierbcom.
É um site americano. Infelizmente, se
você quiser utilizar isso aí, você vai
ter que pagar lá o a importação, né?
Mas é um site muito bom. Tá
bem. Vamos paraa próxima.
Tenho 61 anos, tenho resistência à
insulina.
Pera aí só um minutinho.
Estou em alimentação cetogênica, 50 g,
alternada uma vez por semana com low
carb. 50 g de carboidratos, né? Tá
querendo dizer. Tem esteatose hepática
grau um. Tomo berberina, criimarina. Tá
vendo aí, ó? Berberina também é bom para
fígado, tá? Eu não falei, mas também é
bom para fígado. Sinimarina,
polivitamínico pura vida, alfa. Quase
tudo metil, trimagato, taurato,
glicinato. Blocal, meia-noite também tem
magnésio, bisiglicinato. Tudo pura vida.
Pergunta, é muito magnésio? Depende, tem
que fazer as contas, tá, né? Não sei nem
quantos miligram tá tomando. Como é que
eu vou falar que é muito?
Eh, não é muito pelo fato você tá
tomando várias
variedades do magnésio. Você tem que
fazer as contas de quantos miligram de
magnésio
elementar você tá tomando por dia, tá?
Isso aí você vai ter que fazer
pesquisando na internet. Devo tirar o
trimag? Não sei. Depende da quantidade
que você tá tomando. Minha glicada já
desceu de 5,9 para 5,2. Parabéns.
Insulina de 20 para 17. Já tá
melhorando. Vamos ver se baixa para
baixo de 10. Triglica de 115. Hum. Tá
indo bem. Durmo bem com essa combinação.
Qual a sua opinião? Minha opinião eh é o
que eu te falei, tá? Eh, novamente,
parabéns aí pela queda da hemoglobina
glicada, né? Eh, em termos de magnésio
elementar, recomendação oficial para
mulheres adultas é entre 310 a 320 mg
por dia, tá? Mas isso é elementar, tá?
Mas isso pode aumentar também,
dependendo se a pessoa sua muito, se a
pessoa tem muita atividade física, ela
pode precisar de mais magnésio, OK?
Pessoas que fazem cetogênica, geralmente
a a demanda por minerais, pelo menos no
começo, se você tá no começo, etogênico,
é maior porque tem aquele efeito do
ketoflu que a pessoa desidrata no
começo, tá? Então tem que ficar atenta
em relação a isso daí.
E na verdade é seguro você utilizar o
magnésio, porque a hipermagnesemia
ela é difícil acontecer em pessoas que
têm função renal normal e geralmente dá
diarreia quando você erra a mão na no
magnésio, tá?
Bem, vamos lá eh continuar aqui.
Por gentileza, doutor, atualizações
sobre a B17 amigalina. Foi me prescrito
500 mg, mas ainda não estou bem
convencido a respeito da substância.
Olha, eu tem muito tempo que eu não leio
sobre amdarina. Eu fiz até um vídeo
sobre isso, se eu não me engano, mas tem
bastante tempo. Não duvido do seu
potencial terapêutico, mas temo pela
toxicidade. É, eu tomaria muito cuidado,
tá? Fiz bastantes pesquisas, mas só
aparece indicações negativando o uso.
Seria seguro usar essa dosagem por 2
meses, por exemplo?
Dois meses? Eu vejo que sim, tá? Não
acho que 2 meses é um tempo que seja
complicado, tá?
O problema da midalina é que tem
conversão em sianeto no intestino
delgado, tá? Eh, então você tem que
tomar muito cuidado com isso. Eh, o
médico te prescreveu,
tem que tá acompanhando isso de perto,
tá? Para você ter uma ideia, se de fato
tem 500 mg aí na sua dose, isso vai
liberar aproximadamente 30 mg de ceaneto
que tá chegando perto da dose
que é tóxica, que é 50 mg, tá? Então tem
relatos documentados de toxicidade com
essa dosagem, tá? Pode dar insuficiência
hepática. Eu sinceramente eu vou até te
falar o seguinte, não toma isso, não.
Para de tomar isso aí, conversa com o
médico te prescreveu, tá? Eu acho que o
risco não compensa,
porque você pode ter insuficiência
hepática, renal, encefalopatia, tá?
E se você associar com vitamina C, o
risco aumenta, tá? que a vitamina C ela
potencializa a conversão pro caneto,
então eu não utilizaria. Tá?
Vamos lá. Vamos pra próxima.
Onde eu compro pó de glicina, pó de
magnésio, glicinato de qualidade sem
receita? Pode fazer integritar. Eu já
conversei com eles lá, quando vem uma
solicitação de vocês do grupo, eles me
avisam. Se eu vejo que não é nenhuma
loucura, não é nenhuma coisa perigosa,
eu libero lá, tá bom? Então, se quiser
fazer integritar.com.br,
eles podem fazer. Eh, se eles ficarem
assim relutantes, eles entram em contato
comigo, eu converso com eles, tá bom?
Sendo coisas assim mais tranquilas, tipo
magnésio, ômega, vitamina D, por aí vai.
Dá para você fazer isso daí, tá bom?
Viu, Líbia?
Ah, vamos lá.
Pera aí.
O Natural Max é difícil de encontrar.
Poderia indicar uma farmácia magistral
que tem um ativo? A integritar tem.
Integritar tem o Naturx. E na verdade
ele vem de uma fábrica, foi, até visitei
a fábrica do Natural Max F interior aqui
de São Paulo. Ela ele vai ele vem de uma
fábrica
que eu esqueci o nome da fábrica agora,
fui lá me fugiu o nome agora. Mas quem
compra da fábrica e vende paraas
manipulações é a Caldic, tá? A é a
fornecedora CaldIC, tá? Então realmente
ele é meio chato de achar às vezes, viu?
Mas conversa com a integritar, eles
devem ter isso daí, tá?
Se você não achar de jeito nenhum, você
compra os tocotrienóis do que é extraído
do do óleo de arroz, tá? Mas eu prefiro
do durucum, é melhor qualidade. OK.
A próxima
me dá um minutinho só.
Usei uma pomada nos lábios. A dexa
pantenol por muito tempo. Um dia
amanheceu inchado e doendo. Coloquei
gelo, acalmou e permaneci usando somente
manteiga de cacau. Mesmo com uma semana
de chuvas por aqui, continua seco os
lábios, incomodando muito. Todo período
maus eh sério do acontecido são de fato
20 dias, tá? Tem 20 dias que aconteceu
isso. Tem alguma dica para mim? Sim,
sim. É, você deve ter tido uma reação
inflamatória ou dematite de contato com
o Dex Pantenol. Então, toma cuidado com
isso, não usa mais esse produto, tá? Eh,
ele geralmente é bem tolerado, porém é
possível sim reações alérgicas de mat de
contato.
Parece que foi exatamente isso que
aconteceu com você.
O fato de ter ficado inchado e dolorido
é porque a barreira labial foi
comprometida e você fez bem correto de
interromper o uso imediatamente. Então
você faz o seguinte, descansa os seus
lábios, não passa nenhum produto por
enquanto, só hidratação com água
filtrada, chás antiinflamatórios,
camomila, gengibre, tá? Depois de você
descansar esse período, fica muito bem
hidratada também, viu? Use só óleos
naturais para hidratar os lábios, tá?
tipo óleo de coco, extrav, manteiga de
cacau, pode usar um bálsamo à base de
própolis e mel, tá bom? Então, evite
contato com produtos que você não
conheça
e se não melhorar a situação nos
próximos dias e a gente uma consulta com
dermatologista.
Bem, vamos pra próxima aqui. Boa noite,
Dr. TSH em se justifica um colesterol
acima de 300. Ah, bom que você sabe
dessa história aí do colesterol ter
relação com TSH.
Eh, para quem já faz uma dieta pobre em
carboidrato e quase zero de açúcar, tem
um consumo maior de carnes bovinas. Sim,
sim. Eh, isso é uma reação eh que é
esperada, um TSH
alto, assim como ah LH e FSH alto por
conta de nas mulheres a menopausa, pode
justificar o aumento do colesterol pelo
organismo, tá?
Eh, pessoas que têm essa questão dos
carboidratos baixos, né, fazendo dieta
cetogênicolocarb
e consumindo mais carne vermelha, pode
ter esse aumento de TSH. Então, o
hipotiroidismo, mesmo que leve, ele
reduz significativamente a degradação do
colesterol e aumenta a produção do LDL.
Isso também acontece com as mulheres que
estão na menopausa, porque o organismo
tenta compensar a falta de hormônio
esteroide que vem do colesterol através
do aumento do próprio colesterol, tá?
Então são dois mecanismos de ação
diferente, mas que podem aumentar o
colesterol. Então o que realmente
importa não é o colesterol total tá
elevado, mas sim se você tá tendo
predominância de LDL de partículas
pequenas e densas que oxidam, né? Então,
seria interessante você fazer exames aí
de apolipoproteína B, a polipoína A e
também vê o T4 livre, o T3 livre, tá?
E lembrar que com TSH elevado pode ter
uma redução do tamanho das partículas de
LDL, tornando elas mais propensas
oxidação. São as tais partículas de LDL
pequenas e densas, que são justamente as
mais aterogênicas, as que formam eh a
calcificação na parede da artéria. Então
vai investigar sua tireode, faça os
exames que eu falei, T3 livre, T4 livre,
os anticorpos, né, antitiroidianos,
vai pesquisar deficiência de
micronutriente de selênio, de iodo, de
zinco, de cobre, de ferro, vitamina
complexo B, vitamina D, vitamina C.
Você cuidando desses micronutrientes e
melhorando a sua função tiroidiana, é
provável que o colesterol vai voltar ao
normal sozinho, tá?
e faço a pro A pro B, como eu te
orientei aqui.
Boa noite. Gostaria da sua opinião, só
um minutinho,
eh, sobre os produtos para disbiose
fúngica que utilizam um peroxido
hidrogênio a 3%.
Alimentar por 14 dias, como você sugere
a utilização pensando em disbiose?
Usar quantas gotas em média?
usarem água destilada ou água normal,
usarem jejum duas vezes ao dia. Olha, eu
nunca usei peróxido hidrogênio para
disbiose fúnga, não. Geralmente eu uso
antifúng naturais, são fitoterápicos.
Não sou exatamente contra utilizar o
peróxido de hidrogênio,
mas temos que ter algumas preocupações
relativas a esse protocolo.
Usar o peróxido hidrogênio por muito
tempo vioral eh pode prejudicar a sua
microbiota, né? Pode matar as bactérias
boas além dos fungos, tá? Então, talvez
seja melhor você usar prata coloidal de
boa qualidade ou utilizar talvez até o,
eu não posso mais prescrever isso, né,
porque foi demonizado, mas pensar até em
utilizar o CDS, tá?
Então, eu não sou exatamente contraxid
hidrogênio, mas eu não tenho experiência
pessoal com isso daí e eu recomendaria
cautela, OK?
E é muito importante tirar a comida do
fungo, né, da da cândida, tirar o
açúcar, tirar os processados
industrializados, tirar o glúten, tirar
o leite, tá? Isso é muito importante.
Eu usaria antifúng naturais ou o, como
eu falei, o a prata coloidal
ou mesmo o CDS. OK.
Ah,
ok. Perguntei no grupo a você se era
normal uma pessoa medir a acetose em
1,2. Sim, nesse momento eu estava me
sentindo fraco às 11 horas e e umas 4
horas depois tá 03. já não estava me
sentindo fraco, pois tinha comido carne,
sendo que não consumi carboidrato. Uma
pessoa no grupo me respondeu que tem que
medir a glicose e acetona e fazer um
cálculo de acordo com o resultado. A
minha cetose pode estar registrada em 03
normal. Sua visão, por favor, gente,
coloca ponto nas coisas. Eh, ele diz que
também que se a tose profunda
é mais curativa que terapêutica.
Ué, curativa e terapêutico não é a mesma
coisa. E para manter cetose alta tem que
ser 70, 80% de gordura.
Depende, tá? Isso é muito variável de
pessoa para pessoa. Se eu não estou
comendo carboidrato, a glicemia glicose
não devia estar baixa automaticamente
porque tem um site para medir isso.
Gente, tá um pouco confusa essa
pergunta. Aqueles que fazem dieta de
forma profional e profunda tem que medir
síntese glicose, tá? Vamos lá. Vamos lá.
Primeiro, quem entra em cetose, 1, pouco
de eh de cetose não é uma coisa que faz
mal, não, tá?
03 não é cetose. A gente começa a falar
em cetose 05 para cima, tá?
Ã,
vamos lá. Eh, você tava em 1,2.
Talvez a ingestão de proteína da carne
estimulou a gluconeogênese, que é a
formação de glicose a partir de
aminoácidos, que são glicogênicos. Isso
acontece no fígado. Isso pode aumentar
um pouco a glicose e reduzir a
necessidade de mobilizar os corpos
cetônicos e baixar os corpos cetônicos,
tá? A fraqueza pode ter sido relacionado
a você não tá acostumado a entrar em
cetose
devido à oscilação metabólica ou até por
causa da desidratação inicial que
acontece para quem não tá acostumado,
que tá perdendo líquidos. É tal da queto
flu.
Então o que importa não é só o nível de
cetona isolado, mas a proporção entre
glicose e cetona. Tá correto essa
informação aí do colega?
Esse essa essa esse índice, né, o G K
pode estar entre 07 e 2. Então é bom
você medir glicose mesmo sem os
carboidratos, porque o seu corpo produz
glicose internamente através de glicerol
da gordura e também através dos
aminoácidos. Então não é só da dos
carboidratos.
Eh, o que determina se você tá mantendo
cetose é se essa glicose tá controlada o
suficiente para permitir a mobilização
de gordura.
E 70, 80% de gordura seria muito, na
minha opinião, sim. É por volta de 60%
que você vai entrar em cetose, tá? Paraa
maioria das pessoas que t atividade
física regular, tá bom?
E tem que ter boas gorduras, ômega-3,
azeite de oliva, né? Peixes gordos, ovos
caipiras,
abacate, coco. OK? Cuidado, não vai usar
a gordura processada.
Eh, cetose profunda seria entre três e
5. É muito difícil ver alguém chegar
três e cinco sem ser diabético, tá?
Geralmente eu vejo uma dificuldade muito
grande das pessoas chegar a um, quanto
mais chegar a três, tá? Eh, na epilepsia
seria interessante chegar até três da
cetose,
mas eu pra maioria das pessoas eu
colocaria entre um e três, tá? Que seria
a faixa ideal.
E a fraqueza que você teve pode ter sido
falta de água, de hidratação e falta de
eletrólitos, né, de minerais, porque
você pode estar no começo de eh da dieta
ainda, tá fazendo adaptação cetogênica e
teve a ketoflu. OK.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
A essência de andoba pode tomar gotas
para artrite junto com Copaíba?
Bem, primeiro e não é a essência, tá? É
o óleo de andiroba. Então, o óleo de
andiroba ele é eficaz quando você passa
diretamente em cima da pele da
articulação e massageando, tá?
Ele tem ação antifamatória, analgésica,
atua na dor, muito útil para artrite,
para reumatismo. A Copaíba é maravilhosa
também com antiflamatório, né? Tem uma
ação muito parecida com cannabis, a
Copaíba, né? Ela pode ser tomada
internamente em gotas e pode ser
utilizado também eh topicamente, mas é
mais usado em gotas interno.
Então você pode associar os dois, o
andirobo externo e a compaíba interno.
Ambos têm ação antiinflamatória muito
boa,
tá? Tá? Então você pode tranquilamente
utilizar os dois,
usar a copaíba internamente enquanto
você massageia com andiroba externamente
sobre articulação.
Não tem nenhuma contraindicação de
usá-las juntas,
tá bom? Então fique tranquilo,
tranquila. No caso, tenho usado só um
minutinho, pera aí. Pá.
Tenho usado muitas fórmulas para baixar
a homocisteína. Baixo um pouco, mas não
tudo. Alguma sugestão? Já percebi que
muitos casos tem relação com focos de
infecção. Sim, se você tá com infecção
oculta, pode estar aumentando cisteína,
sim. Tá? Ou se você tiver problema de
função renal, também pode aumentar a
cisteína,
ok?
Então, infelizmente, aoscisteína é um
marcador inflamatório e também de
metilação. Ele pega as duas coisas.
Então é confuso às vezes você
interpretar homo sistêm na alta.
Então quando a gente tem
hiperhomossistenemia
que resiste ao tratamento convencional
com vitamina complexo B, com colina,
eh com, por exemplo, com
trimitioglicina,
com
creatina, tudo isso baixa, né, ômega-3.
Então, precisamos investigar as
deficiências
além das deficiências nutricionais
simples, né? Então, focos de infecção
crônica. Aí já falou muito bem da dos
focos de cavidade oral, absesso
dentário, gengivite, periodontite,
nodontia mal realizada.
Qualquer foco inflamatório no seu corpo
de infeccioso pode aumentar a
homocistena, sim. Tá? Então, faça uma
avaliação odontológica completa,
rigorosa,
de preferência com dentista biológico,
que vai poder também pesquisar as
cavitações, os nicos, OK?
Veja também como é que tá sua saúde
intestinal, sua saúde gástrica, se tem
liquigante, se tem disbiose.
É muito importante checar essas coisas
aí, tá?
Veja como está a função renal, veja como
está a função hepática.
A, o zinco também tem a V, tá? Se tiver
zinco baixo, às vezes aumenta a
homocisteína.
E vejo os alimentos inflamatórios também
que podem estar contribuindo para esse
aumento de homocisteína.
Pra próxima.
Boa noite, doutor. Tem alguma
suplementação para criança autista? Que
meu filho, eu queria ver um remédio para
ajudar a aprendizagem. Ele grau um.
Então ele é nível de cuidado um, então
tem muita coisa dá para fazer, tá? Eu
começaria pelo intestino,
vê se a saúde intestinal eh dele ou dela
tá tá legal.
É muito comum os autistas terem
problemas de liquigante, intestino
hiperpermeável.
Além disso, o ômega-3 é muito bom, né,
para os autistas e usar uma dose
adequada paraa idade e peso dele.
Vitamina D de dado é importante,
magnésio é importante,
probióticos de qualidade pro intestino,
prebióticos de qualidade, né, as fibras,
vitaminas do complexo B, eh se ele for
agitado, usar algaba, ou pode usar
também glicina, pode usar lisina, que
são aminoácidos calmantes, pode usar
eliteanina, que é aminoácido calmante,
tá? Melatonina, se ele tiver distúbroo
de sono de baixa dosagem, pode ajudar
também.
É bem comum autistas ter sono
desregulado,
remover essencialmente da dieta o glúten
e o leite derivado, né, que tem a
caseína. É muito, muito comum autista
ter intolerância a glúten, caseína e
leite.
Eh, investigar eh focos também
infecciosos,
investigar aí causas que possam estar
contribuindo paraa inflamação cerebral.
OK? Mas é um assunto bem complexo esse
aí. Eu até recomendo você, viu,
Lelisson, você ou Yellison, você agendar
aí com a Dra. Simone Pires, que é
entende bastante de autismo. Se você
puder,
na sua visão, já houve estudos rígidos
que mediam pessoas altamente
comprometidas com dieta cetogênica bem
feita por mais de 6 meses com os
objetivos de cura, de depressão, TDAH e
esquizofrenia?
Sim, tem gente que faz a dieta por mais
tempo. Ou na sua visão nunca foi
estudado isso? Não, foi estudado sim.
Eh, vi no GGPT que tem um grupo de
estudiosos, Stephen Finey, Jeff Rolek,
em parceria com Virta Heal Study, fez um
estudo com pessoas de 2 anos, mas mediu
apenas a parte metabólica e chegaram à
conclusão de reversão do diabetes caso
continue com a dieta. Na sua visão,
depois de estudo antes, já foi estudado
na parte mental, se a dieta feita por
mais de 6 meses pode limpar o cérebro,
organismo? Sim, pode
curar. Eu não diria, tá? Eu diria
controlar doenças cerebrais, mas
esquizofrenia não. Seria mais TDH
e depressão.
Aí mais esquizofrenia. Acho que não tá.
Então vamos falar um pouquinho mais
sobre essa literatura internacional
recente, né? Nós temos estudos
promissores, mas ainda são pontuais. A
gente não tem estudos grandes, enormes
sobre a dieta cetogênica nas doenças
neurológicas.
Então eu diria para você que ajudaria no
TDAH, sem dúvida. Não curaria, mas
ajudaria. ajudaria muito na depressão,
mas na esquizofrenia não ajudaria.
Dentro que eu conheço,
esse estudo que você comentou, esse
virta, ele foi interessante, importante
para validar a reversão metabólica do
diabetes, que acontece de fato, mas ele
não avaliou a parte psiquiátrica ou
neurológica.
Tem alguns relatos de estudos pequenos
explorando o eixo intestino cérebro com
a dieta cetogênica e reduzindo
inflamação, mas ainda não tem estudos em
grande escala.
Isso vai demorar ainda para ter, tá? Não
tem tanto estímulo para eh esses estudos
acontecerem.
Então, como vocês sabem, onde não tem
uma droga aí nova que vai vender bilhões
de dólares, não tem muito dinheiro paraa
pesquisa.
OK,
vamos pra próxima.
Quais os melhores suplementos para
osteoporose?
A life extension tem um bone restore
elite. Quais outros na sua opinião?
Então, esse produto da Live Extension é
uma excelente opção, sim. Ele tem uma
dose muito generosa de K2 com MK4.
Eu usaria mais o MK7, mas esse produto
tem o MK4.
E essa fórmula também tem 700 mg de
cálcio. Tem várias formas de alta
absorção do cálcio. Tem vitamina D, tem
zinco, tem magnésio, boro e silício. O
boro e silício frequentemente são
esquecidos na saúde de ossos. São bem
interessantes.
No mercado brasileiro nós temos o
biovitamin cálcio com magnésio, zinco,
D3 e K2. Biovitamin cálcio seria
interessante,
mas não tem aí o boro, nem o
nem o silício
e também não tem uma quantidade muito
significativa de K2.
Sandal é uma marca, você pode pensar Max
Nutri K2 complexo também,
mas o bón restore é melhor, tá? Em
termos de K2.
Então, se você puder ter acesso ao
bonite ou elite, é a melhor opção dentro
dessas que eu falei aqui.
Lembre-se de fazer exercício de força,
de resistência, lembre-se de se expor a
luz,
tá bom? e verificar os seus níveis nos
exames de sangue.
Ah, tem também para osteoporose, tem
também o
um outro suplemento aí que me fugiu o
nome agora, que é da Life Extension
também.
Quando lembrar eu falo para vocês aqui.
Dout. falando. Se eu fizer dieta
cetogênica bem feita por mais de 6 meses
e nesse tempo tomar ômega-3 de oliva
dormir 8 horas no horário certo, ele
pode colher bons resultados?
Sim, pode.
Não, essa essa tá repetida essa essa
pergunta. A pessoa, eu mandou duas
vezes. Vamos continuar aqui.
Boa noite. Criança de 1 ano com cólica e
gases. O que posso dar para ajudar?
Posso dar algumas gotas de tintura de
espinheira santa?
É importante primeiro entender porque
essa criança tá com gás, tá? Geralmente
tá relacionado à intolerância alimentar.
com ano de idade, ela provavelmente tá
comendo alimentos sólidos. Então é
importante ver se essa criança não tem
intolerância ao leite de vaca,
sensibilidade também ao glúten.
É bem comum eh as crianças que terem
essas sensibilidades alimentares terem
aumento de gases e desconforto,
tem que ter certeza que ela tá bem
hidratada,
pode entrar com probiótico específico
paraa criança, como é o caso do
lactobacilosere,
que é um bom lactobacilo para cólicas em
bebês, em crianças.
Pode usar camomila,
malva, óleo de linhaça.
Podem acalmar a mucosa.
Espinheira santa. É possível ser
utilizado sim, mas tenha bastante
cautela com a dosagem.
Use uma titura bem diluída, comece com
bastante cuidado, com poucas gotas
e faça sob orientação de um
naturopata aí bem experiente com
crianças ou um pediatracular,
tá certo?
A esperira santa é muito boa para
gastrite inflamação. Eu particularmente
não tenho experiência com criança
pequena porque não trato desse dessas
idades aí,
mas o foco tem que se eliminar a causa
da inflamação, tá? Não só tratar os
sintomas.
Gente, eu tô com a boca seca, eu vou
pegar uma água, já volto, tá? Segura as
pontas aí.
[Música]
Essa pergunta de novo é a terceira vez
que aparece aqui.
A minha filha tem 33 anos, desde 2020
vem tratando o Cifo, que é small
intentional fungalgrowth, ou seja,
excesso de fungo no intestino
diagnosticado através do compromax,
entre outros suplementos e
fisioterápicos.
Toma glutamina, eu gostaria de dar o
butirato. Posso dar junto ou suspendo a
glutamina? Não, pode usar os dois, tá? E
como prescrever o butirato? Então,
butirato
ele é trimebirina que te usa, tá?
Trimebutina, desculpa, não é trimibutina
porque tem os dois nomes muito parecido,
é tributirina, perdão. Então, a
glutamina e a tributirina ou butirato,
eles trabalham de forma complementar,
então um ajuda o outro na recuperação
intestinal. Não tem problema nenhum de
você manter o enquanto tá dando
glutamina, tá bom?
Eles vão
estimular adaptação,
regeneração da mucosa intestinal. Eles
vão modular a regeneração
e vão também ajudar na resposta imune,
vão aumentar as células T, que são
células de defesa,
e também os agotamina butirato vai
potencializar os efeitos
antiinflamatórios e de reconstituição da
barreira intestinal.
Então não há nenhum problema de
associar, tá?
dose do da do butirato, né, do corebiome
é de 300 a 900 mg por dia. Você pode
dividir em duas ou três tomadas, tá?
Então, comece com 300 mg, se não for
suficiente, aumenta para 600 e depois
vai para 900.
Deixa eu ver quantas mais tem. Tem mais
umas 10 perguntas.
Estou grávida e gostaria de uma
suplementação adequada, especialmente
quanto a colina. Além de TDAH, tem
diagnóstico de depressão endógena,
porém passos longos períodos sem uso do
medicamento e sem alterações.
Fiz uso da colina de 1 g por alguns
meses e tive um resultado ótimo.
Contudo, não sei se é seguro manter na
gravidez. Não, colina é comida, tá?
Então é seguro de usar na gravidez, né?
Então colina você tem no ovo, por
exemplo, tá? Outra dúvida, é seguro usar
espirulina em clorela na gravidez?
Então, tem estudos que saíram da
Universidade Cornel mostrando que 930 mg
de ário de colina durante a gravidez é
seguro, mas também é até recomendável
porque é benéfico pro desenvolvimento
cognitivo do bebê, porque na verdade
colina é comida, tá?
H, especialmente para você que tem
histórico de TDH.
Então, 1 gama por dia tá bem próximo da
faixa terapêutica comprovada.
E considerando que 90 a 95% das
gestantes comem menos colina, né, do ovo
do que o recomendado,
eu recomendo sim que você utilize
proculina vai ajudar na metilação, vai
ajudar a controlar homocisteína,
vai ajudar a prevenir os defeitos de
tubo neural, né, que acontece com as
crianças que tm deficiência aí de
metifolato, né, de ácido fólico.
Então
pode manter tranquilamente a
suplementação,
vai ajudar sua criança a evitar o TDH
e a depressão.
E a espirulina e clorela também são
seguras da gravidez, tá?
Gasgre, como vocês perceberam,
tanto a clorela, espirulina tem que ser
de fontes totalmente confiáveis para
usar na gestação para não ter
contaminação por metais pesados. você.
Então, tem que tomar muito cuidado com
isso.
Então, por exemplo, no caso da clorela,
uma boa fonte aí é o
é aquela marca japonesa, como é que é o
nome mesmo?
Ah, anil. Anil. Eles têm uma clorela
muito boa. Eles tm espirulina também, se
eu não me engano.
Então, também me preocuparia com iodo na
gravidez. Tomaria iodo porque é muito
importante pr as crianças. Me praria me
preocuparia com omômega-3.
me preocuparia com vitamina D de dado,
me preocuparia com magnésio. Tudo isso
vai ser muito importante paraa sua
criança crescer saudável no útero e
depois do útero também.
Mas coorden aí com a obstetra que tá
acompanhando. E meus parabéns pela
gravidez, Helen.
Doutor, o que que você acha do uso de
peptídeos para inflamação crônica? Tive
diagnóstico de LIME em junho, fiz
tratamento com antibióticos e agora
estou na fase de manutenção. Você tá
tratando com o Dr. Carlos?
Como é que é o sobrenome dele? Carlos
me fugiu o sobrenome dele agora. Tem um
médico que é fez live comigo uma vez que
ele é especialista Leviche. Carlos
Leviche.
Ele é especialista em lime.
Eh, mas sofro muito com os efeitos da
inflamação decorrentes, dor de cabeça,
dor muscular, dor nas articulações,
cansaço, fadiga. Já faço suplementação
para ajudar, mas ainda não cito
melhoras. Passa com o Dr. Carlos Levich,
né? Ou é ele com que você já acompanha?
Não sei, né? Bem, os peptídios,
infelizmente, a gente não tem como ter
experiência no Brasil, porque no Brasil
não é liberado. Nos Estados Unidos
também é difícil de obter, mas tem
muitos médicos lá da medicina funcional
que estão utilizando. Tem um peptido em
especial que é o BPC 157, B de bola, P
de pato, C de casa, BPC 157, que tem
sido demonstrado que são eh promissores
para inflamação crônica.
Então, esse peptídio que eu acabei de
falar, ele trabalha em mecanismos
fundamentais. Ele aumenta a produção de
óxido nítrico, promove a formação de
vasos, angiogênese, ele regula fatores
de crescimento, que é o caso do Vegf,
que é o vascular endutilal growth
factor. Ele reduz citocinas
inflamatórias,
ele tem eficácia e cicatrização de
micose intestinal, ele ajuda na
regeneração de tecidos e para lime seria
uma boa se você conseguir importar isso
aí, mas geralmente tem que trazer contra
a bandeada dos Estados Unidos, tá? De
novo BPC 157.
Mas é complicado,
tá? Mas veja se você pode passar com Dr.
Carlos Levich que tem experiência.
Dá uma avaliada também se você não tem
disbiose, tem problema de
hiperpermeabilidade intestinal, não tem
excesso de LDL oxidado,
retire o glúten e laticínios da dieta.
Use ômega-3 em doses mais altas junto
com a vitamina D. Use curcomina de alta
absorção. Eu tenho uma live que eu falo
sobre isso procurando no canal.
Pode pensar em usar ozônio,
tá? Pode usar queelação de metais de
indicação, tá bom?
Ah.
É possível indicar fornecedores
confiáveis de lite orotato? Tem da CAL,
tá? K A L. K A L. A CAL é um é um é um
dos principais fornecedores de lítio
orotato ou orotato de lítio. A Life
Extension também é uma excelente opção.
Então para comprar tem que comprar pelo
site do IERB, tá? ou de outros
importadores.
Você pode estar tomando de 5 a 10 mg por
dia do orotato de lítio.
Mais fácil com compento médico, tá? É
mais recomendado.
Ah, já tá repetida essa pergunta aqui.
Além da vitamina E, quais outras
substâncias potencializa com enzima Q10?
Bem, a combinação mais importante e da
cozema 10, além da vitamina E é o PQQ,
tá? E também a creatina.
Eles se complementam para otimizar a
função mitocondrial e para produção de
energia.
Ômega3 também vai ser muito útil porque
todas as substâncias são liposolúveis
e ômega-3 ele potencializa os efeitos
antioxidantes
contra os radicais livres.
Você pode usar também as tachantina, né,
que é um flavonoide muito bom e
antiinflamatório.
Ele vai ajudar também na ação da
comenzima Q10.
Você pode usar os carotenoides, né, como
é o caso da luteína.
Os minerais, o zinco, magnésio e selênio
quando estão indicados,
eh, quando eles são combinados com a
cozema que 10, há uma potencialização
dos efeitos na proteção contra os danos
oxidativos.
Importante consumir o comozinho Q10 com
gordura saudável, tá? Seja azeite de
oliva, seja ôega-3, seja peixe, porque
tomando com gordura vai aumentar a
absorção em até oito vezes.
Vamos pra próxima.
Magnésio pode ser tomado com ei isolado
ou blend de ervilhas e arroz? Sim, pode.
Não tem problema nenhum se associar o
magnésio com proteína, tá? seja o ei ou
seja ervilha ou arroz,
eles vão até trabalhar de maneira
complementar. A proteína vai favorecer a
síntese muscular e recuperação e o
magnésio vai potencializar a função
muscular.
E ao potencializar a função muscular, o
magnésio também ajuda na absorção de
proteína e reduz a inflamação.
E o magnésio é importante para quem
treina pesado, porque vai melhorar a
recuperação e reduzir o dano muscular.
Então você pode juntar no mesmo shake
sem problema nenhum.
E geralmente eu recomendo somente o
isolado
e não o concentrado, tá?
Porque o isolado não vai ter com a
lactose nem caseína que vai ser
inflamatória.
Pode tomar clidade betaína, corebiô,
curcumina, acetil, cisteína, ácido
alfalipô, polivitamina, tudo junto após
o almoço.
Sim, você pode juntar esses suplementos
depois do almoço.
O cloridate betaína ele vai aumentar a
acidez do estômago, vai melhorar a
digestão.
A cucumina é lipossolúvel, então ela vai
bem com alimentos, né, que você vai
comer gordura junto.
O corebiome, o NAC e o polivitamínico
geralmente não tem conflitos, mas é bom
você, se puder, tomar as vitaminas
liposolúveis junto com a alimentação e
as hidrossolúveis um pouquinho longe,
também até potencializa aí a absorção. A
ressalva aí dessa lista é o alfalipoico.
O alfalipoico ele é melhor absorvido em
jejum,
tá? Mas não é que não vai ser absolvido
com alimento, mas diminui um pouco a
absorção.
Eh, como você atua em pacientes com SHBG
muito elevados, homens e mulheres?
Primeira coisa que tem que ver, tá,
é se por esse esse HBG aumentou. Não é
só batendo na SH HBG porque ele é
inimigo, não. Tem que ver porque que ele
aumentou. tá te protegendo ele.
Então tem que ver a função tireudiana
completa, tem que ver os marcadores
inflamatórios, vê se tem resistência
insulínica, vê a função hepática.
SH HBG elevado pode ser desnutrição,
pode ser inflamação crônica,
pode ser hipertiroidismo,
pode ser excesso de fitoestrógenos na
dieta.
Então é importante a gente limpar a
dieta primeiro, tirar o glúten, lactose,
leites derivados,
ajuste calórico, né? Não ter excesso de
calorias,
entrar com exercício físico,
entrar com micronutrientes, magnésio,
complexo B, vitamina D
e ver se o SHBG não vai cair sozinho,
tá?
E se tudo isso for descartado e SH HBG
continuar alto, você pode utilizar
alguns fitoterápicos, como é o caso da
Ortiga Dioica e do Long Jack, que eles
ajuda a baixar o SHBG.
Você
disse no YouTube que o suplemento 5 HTP
deve ser tomado no início em baixas
doses e aumentando aos poucos. Me dá um
exemplo para quem quer atingir a dose de
100 mg por dia.
Não é isso aí. Você pode pular do 50
para 100 tranquilamente, não precisa
ficar passando pelo 70 não, tá? Você
pode tomar 50 e depois
uma semana não tiver problema, você tá
para 100, não tem problema nenhum, tá?
Bem, aí e se você quisesse aumentar além
de 100 mg, aí você poderia estar subindo
de 100 em 100, tá? Mas geralmente eu não
eu não prescrevo mais do que 200 mg de 5
HTP não.
E se você for tomar 200 ou 300, você tem
que dividir ao longo do dia, tá?
Há muito tempo fiquei sabendo que eu
posso fazer musculação de manhã em
jejum, desde que na refeição das 18 do
dia anterior consuma batata doce.
Qualquer alimento com carboidrato no
lugar da batalhador serviria se for um
carboidrato complexo, né?
Tem que ser um carboidrato complexo com
fibra.
Bem, eu acho que a maioria das pessoas
que estão bem adaptados à cetose vão
poder treinar em jejum de manhã cedo
tranquilamente, independente do que
comeram na noite anterior, tá?
E na verdade você pode até comer uma
banana ou um pouco de batata doce uma
meia hora antes do treino, tá? Que isso
pode ajudar também no seu desempenho na
força muscular, tá?
Vamos lá pra próxima. Correlação frango
orgânico, receber antibiótico. Fiquei
sabendo que a certificação para produção
orgânica no Brasil aceita a inclusão de
antibióticos, desde que esses
antibióticos sejam terapêuticos.
É porque é o seguinte, a todo
antibiótico, na verdade, deveria ser
terapêutico, né?
O que eles estão dizendo aqui é que era
comum antigamente eh você ter a situação
deles darem um antibiótico paraa ave,
mesmo ela não tendo nenhum tipo de
infecção, porque eles percebiam que a
ave ficava pesada mais rápido, ela
engordava mais rápido, tá?
Então esse termo significa que o
antibiótico tá sendo utilizado para
tratar uma infecção real e não tá sendo
dado indiscriminadamente para todas as
aves, tá? É isso que quer dizer isso aí.
Porque antigamente era utilizado como
profilático e promotor de crescimento.
Mas o ideal realmente seria você ingerir
a carne de uma ave que não teve contato
com nenhum tipo de antibiótico,
se fosse possível, né?
Hã,
já respondi. Essa tá repetida.
H, doutor, quem tem pressão arterial
baixa pode consumir taurina 45 anos
pequeno derrame no pericárdio? Sim,
pode.
A taurina é muito segura, tá? Na verdade
é um dipeptídio, né? São dois
aminoácidos juntos. Muito bom para
coração, para cérebro, muito bom para
depressão, ansiedade, muito bom para eh
pessoas que têm fadiga crônica, é muito
bom também para controle de pressão
arterial. Eh, pode baixar pressão
arterial, deve ser por isso que você tá
perguntando, mas eu nunca vi a taurina
sozinha causar hipotensão, tá? Ou seja,
ela sozinha causar queda de pressão
arterial, mas vai devagar, começa com
200 mg por dia, né?
Vai testando, vai subindo aos
pouquinhos, tá? A dose terapeuta
geralmente de 500 mg até 2 g por dia.
Sobre as picadinhas, doutor, tem notado
aumento nos casos de problemas
cerebrais? Sim, tá aumentando Alzheimer
e tá aumentando depressão, tá aumentando
ansiedade,
tá aumentando eh autismo,
aumento de problemas de coração também
tem mais infarto, tem mais AVC
isquêmico,
seja aqui ou fora do país. Acha que os
casos são maiores do que o noticiado?
Sim, são maiores do que o noticiado. Tá,
tá bem claro isso daí.
Beleza, pessoal?
Seja bem-vinda, Carla Cristina, novo
membra. Nova membra é fogo. Novo membro
ou nova membro, não sei como é que fala.
Enfim.
Ô, Eliseu, por favor, eu não vou
responder as perguntas ao vivo hoje não,
tá? Porque é muita pergunta. Já estamos.
Que horas são agora? Nem sei que horas
são.
Eh, são 10 paraas 9. Eu vou encerrar a
live, tá, pessoal? Muito obrigado então
pela presença de vocês. Foi um prazer
estar aqui com vocês
e a gente vai se falando
até a próxima semana. Um beijo no
coração.